[Música]
olá
agora eu vou abrir um livro pra vocês um
livro de 18 minutos e vocês vão ler esse
livro eu vou contar pra vocês a minha
trajetória de 40 anos que eu vou fazer
40 este ano e desde criança e eu tive
que resolver coisas da minha vida porque
era uma criança surda e como que era
minha vida
então as pessoas normalmente me
perguntam é você fala diferente
você é brasileira você é espanhola
você é francesa
porque você tem uma voz diferente
eu sou surda
eu sou brasileira eu sou brasileira sim
eu uso a língua de sinais e eu faço
oralização também engraçado que eu gosto
quando as pessoas me perguntam isso eu
fico tão orgulhosa às vezes eu brinco
com a pessoa fala assim a sua espanhola
mas depois de abrir fogo não eu sou
brasileira
então o que aconteceu eu quando eu nasci
em aracaju e vem para o rio e eu comecei
a ficar doente
fiquei internada há 26 dias e melhorei
o médico falou pra minha mãe falou olha
a sua filha ela pode ter algumas
sequelas é preciso observá lo pode ser
cega pode ter problemas cognitivos minha
mãe deixou depois de três meses minha
mãe descobriu que eu fiquei surdo porque
minha mãe me chamava eu ficava brincando
brincando minha mãe falava clarissa
clarice eu não entendia
ela me levou para o médico falou que eu
posso fazer com a sua filha sua filha
surda
minha mãe ficou desesperada porque falta
informação naquela época na década de 80
se faltava muita informação hoje em dia
é muito mais fácil
e aí eu reflito com vocês eu sou da
minha mãe quando me viu surda
ela precisava fazer uma escolha ou ela
me levava pra catar para fazer fono ou
colocava me colocar pra fazer libras
ela tinha que fazer uma escolha se eu
não fosse surdo
eu teria uma outra realidade então
quando era criança era inocente brincava
com outras crianças sempre brincando
brincava com crianças de várias raças e
etnias pra mim era todo mundo igual eu
não me percebia como surda foi para uma
escola particular e na escola particular
que acontecia brincava com as crianças
só que o grupo de mães e os outros
alunos quando me viram uma menina que
usa as mãos pra falar começaram a
separar os filhos num que não deixava
mais brincar comigo eo grupo de mães
resolveu fazer um abaixo assinado para
me tirar da escola porque as mães
pensavam que eu era uma doença
contagiosa é minha mãe ficou muito
triste porque em casa e tinha problemas
obviamente a emitir minha mãe tirou da
escola me colocou numa escola na gávea
que é uma escola que tinha crianças
surdas e ouvintes uma escola bilíngue e
pra mim eu não sabia o que era surdez eu
não queria ficar perto das crianças
surdas
eu pretendo surda não queria eu ficava
só junto com a professora e eu sei que
normalmente há no caso das mães que me
fizeram sair da escola eu sei que era
falta de informação a falta de
informação gera preconceito
às vezes nós vemos crianças autistas
deficientes visuais cadeirantes essas
crianças pessoas elas geram preconceito
somos todos iguais
a única diferença é a deficiência só
isso
para isso somos todos iguais somos
humanos
importa somos humanos todos iguais e na
minha família
o trio prioritariamente eles me ajudaram
muito me trata minha família me tratava
igual aos meus irmãos e à minha mãe por
sempre me tratar igual a todo mundo ela
deixou viajar com a minha irmã com uma
viagem eu fiquei toda feliz que a árvore
estados unidos numa viagem com a minha
irmã era só eu e ela numa excursão da
escola
vocês sabem que um ônibus de turismo tem
o guia turístico que vai falando eu não
entendia nada e ficava só vendo que
passava ficava na paisagem e chegou em
miami e meu irmão falou pra mim fica aí
fica aí eu vou lá e volto
aí eu falei tá aí fiquei esperando
esperando esperando e nada da hora
passar e passava e nada de ninguém
chegar
fiquei perdida aí eu fiquei procurando o
pessoal do grupo que estava todo mundo
camisa azul nome sozinhas nos estados
unidos em miami
surdo não sabia falar inglês o que eu ia
fazer eu falei vou voltar pro hotel o
que eu fiz eu não fiquei nervosa eu
voltei pelo mesmo caminho que o ônibus
passou quando cheguei no hotel eu via
todo mundo ali meu ônibus está ali
esqueceu de mim era pra tá chorando
desesperada eu falei não vou nem eu era
uma criança tranquila subir o elevador
quando cheguei no andar e vi um grupo de
pessoas em cima de uma pessoa quando eu
vi era minha irmã que estava chorando
muito muito muito e eu perguntei por que
está chorando
todo mundo fala assim áries você
apareceu a van e me puxou todo mundo
ficou muito desesperado foi engraçado
até hoje eu entendo porque na época eu
não entendia quero que esta preocupação
a partir daí minha mãe confiou em mim
porque minha mãe via que eu como não
ouvia nada a minha percepção visual era
muito
muito grande porque eu ficava muito
atenta às coisas à volta
a icon de corredores a minha família
cuidava de mim taí eu passei no
vestibular para petrópolis e meu pai
falou
clarissa você vai ter que morar sozinha
aí eu
caramba passei para o vestibular de
engenharia mecânica e engenharia
mecânica
eu queria seguir na época foi seguir a
profissão do meu pai
estudei lá na petrópolis e tomou um suco
da não você não pode estar aqui
quem está cuidando de você aqui não me
dá um número de telefone da sua mãe a
professora falava e ligou para a minha
mãe e minha mãe falou assim calma fica
tranquila porque a professora tinha um
filho deficiente isso em 99 tinha alguma
informação só que os aí já que meus pais
sempre me incentivavam sempre me deram
asas
eles não cortavam minhas asas
eu estudei para os professores passaram
a confiar em mim
só que em 2002
eu estava estudando engenharia mecânica
antes só que eu não estava me sentindo
bem não estava feliz quando eu vi aí eu
vi meu irmão água na faculdade meu irmão
larga na faculdade eu falei assim porque
tem que fazer uma coisa imposta eu tenho
direito
eu tenho direito de escolha aí eu
resolvi largar engenharia mecânica
porque não era algo que eu gostava
óbvio que isso cria um problema dentro
de casa porque eu decidi que queria ser
feliz que o que eu ia escolher o caminho
que eu quisesse meu pai virou pra mim é
você largou a faculdade vai ter que
trabalhar comigo eu falei não não vou
trabalhar
meu pai falou então você vai procurar
emprego na rua
nossa foi muito difícil eu vi o quão
difícil é uma pessoa deficiente que
garantir o emprego
surgiram para mim oportunidades de
arrumadeira do hotel
eu tentei mas porque ele falar se á não
porque esta classe pra perceber receber
trabalha com isso eu parei pra pensar
pra
isso foi bom porque eu pude aprender eu
pude aprender o que acontece de verdade
no mundo e me deu persistência para
lutar e não era fácil comecei a procurar
e e me colocar nos lugares e nas pessoas
nas empresas porque infelizmente a
questão do emprego geralmente são sub
empregos
normalmente pessoas deficientes eles não
têm um emprego igual às outras pessoas
aí eu não consegui emprego e comecei a
fazer um curso de libras
aí em 2006 eu me identifiquei como surda
eu não queria colocar implante eu queria
ter o direito como suja eu fiz letras
libras em 2006 era difícil porque os
surdos mesmo falou assim ah você
oralizada e eu me esforçava aprender a
língua de sinais
aí quando me formei em 2011 eu fiz após
aqui na ufrj na primeira turma de
tradução e interpretação e me formei e
na ufrj
eu era professora temporária aí foi
criada uma nova turma de letras libras
noturno foi criado aqui na ufrj
eu comecei a refletir o foco geralmente
ficar muito preso a uma área
eu sabia que eu precisava ampliar minha
bagagem eu precisava conhecer outros
lugares
aí eu fui na áfrica foi na costa rica
fui para espanha e itália e fui em
alguns países na frança
fui vários países porque porque eu
precisava ter esse contato com outras
pessoas surdas pra me mostrar pra ter
certeza de que a gente poderia ampliar a
gente sabe que a língua de sinais ela
não é universal é igual às outras
línguas que cada país tem a sua e eu
precisava ampliar minha bagagem cultural
de conhecimento
aí conheci vários lugares porque eu
precisava ter esse conhecimento
eu não prefiro não podia deixar minha
bagagem vazia porque eu precisava
dividir isso com outros surdos
então a experiência foi muito importante
e aí em 2014
foi um ano que foi surpreendente para
mim porque eu comecei a trabalhar no
programa superação que era um programa
de esportes da tv enes e no trabalho a
gente começou a fazer filmagens gente
via muitos jornalistas no e vários
jornalistas lá fazer a entrevista e
quando eu fui falar todo mundo me olhou
com olhar de surpresa mas a lítio vários
idiomas e eu sei que ninguém tinha nunca
tinha visto uma reportagem a
apresentadora em libras
então ainda ainda tem muito que se
visibilidade ainda falta isso é
importante para ajudar a comunidade
surda e também a experiência de
interagir com outros ambientes não só no
esporte como repor várias reportagens e
há pouco tempo eu fiz uma entrevista com
refugiados na venezuela
suco do que que saiu da venezuela vai
pra cá e vem e vendam seu jeito de
vender as coisas e ao mesmo tempo eu fui
chamada e teve o concurso aqui pra ufrj
e fui chamada pra mim pro ferry jc
professora daqui
essa é a primeira turma que foi formado
no ano passado embaixo é a outra turma
que está formando então é o que eu penso
ser minha missão lembrando lá atrás
porque eu sou surda quando era mais nova
fala assim porque eu sou surda porque a
sua surda eu resolvi parar de falar isso
parar de pensar porque eu sou surdo eu
comecei a falar eu sou humana
a única diferença que eu tenho de
comunicação as pessoas falou assim ah
você é surda
as pessoas às vezes fogem de mim ficam
assustados e falou não vem aqui vamos
tentar
a única diferença é a língua só isso
simples simplesmente a única diferença
a língua quando uma pessoa de outro país
vêem as pessoas não tentam se esforçar
conversar porque comigo não
então isso é uma coisa que precisa ser
difundido as pessoas têm medo às vezes
de um surdo
ali a libras é uma língua então eu sei
que a minha missão é ser surda
eu estou aqui pra passar para os outros
surdos principalmente desde a base desde
os pequenos até os maiores
então é importante passar isso então é
eu vendo na foto ali na foto é só uma
criança inocente e eu fui crescendo fui
tendo a minha força no empoderamento pra
comunidade surda
então a minha virtude é o que é ser
surda
eu tenho um filho que já está com 12
anos quando ele era bebê e eu ficava
super preocupada fala assim como é que
eu vou ensinar a ensinar libras pra ele
porque ele precisa aprender a minha
língua
para ele poder como se comunicar comigo
porque é a minha língua
ele é meu marido é surdo também então
meu filho é considerado corda que são os
filhos de pais surdos
então na escola dele tem algumas
matérias que quando teve na aula falou
sobre o fato ele foi lá e ele falou eu
sei eu fiquei orgulhosa de ver isso
porque porque ele entende que a língua
dos pais dele é a língua de sinais
teve um filme que foi uma edição sobre o
meio ambiente a falar assim a filho
coloca a legenda pessoa manhã surda
ele foi lá e fez porque porque ele já
tem essa consciência eu coloco nele essa
consciência porque a maioria dos filmes
não tem legenda então eu falei com o meu
filho porque eu quero que o daqui pra
frente o mundo mude
então agora eu tô fechando o livro da
minha vida e no final eles livro é o meu
nome é clarissa eu sou surda
[Música]